استيقظ الالاف من الاشخاص في بريطانيا على
رساله نصيه من الشرطه تبلغهم انهم بين
ضحايا اكبر عمليه احتلال شهدتها بريطانيا
بمبلغ قيمته 48 مليون جنيه استرليني تمكنت
خليه من المجرمين الالكترونيين من
الاستحواذ على اموال حوالي سبعين الف شخص
في البلاد بمعدل وصل الى 20 شخص في
الدقيقه الواحده وقد بلغت خسائر ضحيه
واحده فقط حوالي ثلاثه ملايين جنيه
2020 في ديسمبر وبلشت بشكل
نوعا ما عشوائي عن طريق موقع السلجرام
التليجرام كانوا عاملين زي الدعايه انه
فيه موقع اسمه ايسكو دوت سي سي
هذا بيعطي تكنولوجي معينه تسمح لكريمنال
انهم يغيروا ارقام التليفونات
استغرقه نحو 45 دقيقه بعد ان تم اهامها
بانها تحت مسائله قانونيه تجبرها على
تجويد المتصل بمعلومات عن حساباتها
البنكيه في لعبه كثير خفت فدخلت حدا من
الزميلات اللي كنت اقترب مننا فعلا عندي
قيمه مستحقه للضرائب الاستبدا قبل الساعه
6:00 فهي تغريد هي بتعرف الامور القانونيه
وهي في البلد
فقالت راميه دغري بتسكري التلفون هذا
فورا قمت انا فورا بالمكالمه
والخبراء المتكرره للمواطنين بعدم اعطاء
اي معلومات خاصه او سريه عبر الهاتف فان
احترافيه المتصل واسلوبه قد ينطليانه على
الكثير
ما زالوا موجودين الان تعرضت انا واصدقائي
لعمليه احتلال لذا اعتقد ان الشرطه على
درايه بهذا الامر وهم يحاولون حقا يظهر
امكانياتهم لمساعده الناس في فهم ما يجري
التقديرات تشير الى ان ضحايا العصابه في
بريطانيا وحدها قد يصلون الى حوالي
200,000 وقد بدا محققوا الشرطه بارسال
رسائل الى حوالي سبعين ممن تلقوا اتصالات
وهميه وتعرضوا للنصب
عمليه الى بريد اكبر عمليه تقوم بها
الشرطه البريطانيه في تاريخها ضد خليه من
المجرمين الالكترونيين الذين نجحوا في
اختلاف الملايين من الجنيهات في عمليه
تسلط الضوء على امكانيه وسهوله مثل هكذا
عمليات حتى في الدول المتقدمه من لندن
عروب عبد الحق العربي